Boris Johnson taking us out of the EU
without the deal would be historically
and laughably undemocratic now I'm not
talking about the fact that Pro brexit
politicians promise people they could
vote to leave without being made poorer
because we come out with a deal I'm
talking about the fact that we voted to
leave the EU on a ballot paper which
said nothing about the relationship we'd
have with the EU afterwards forget all
the rhetoric about economics and
sovereignty the deal that we negotiated
is brexit so is no deal
so as an OE style deal and a can of the
style deal they all mean we leave the EU
the UK has only had one chance to define
what relationship it wants to have with
the European Union that was the 2017
general election in which 54 percent of
voters voted for parties whose
manifestos explicitly ruled out No Deal
so for a country that called the EU
undemocratic to be dragged out of the EU
without the deal against the wishes of
the majority of its voters by a prime
minister that nobody even contemplated
in the last election would be laughably
and historically undemocratic welfare
again welcome because I want to be
polite instead I'm interested actually
because there's been a lot of talk about
the Norwegian model the Canadian model
denoxin the Luxembourg model I'm
delighted Boris's agreed he'll go out
with all of them and see what anyone any
one of them and if look I hear what you
say about the ballot but Femi if you
were in the slightest bit right which
you're not your holiness not explain the
support there is for the brexit party
which in a poll in The Times newspaper
this week is 1 percent behind leading of
the polls you have the Conservatives of
24 you have bricks in at 23 bricks it is
it's on the tin is an unalloyed party
that is why the majority I think as
Nigel Faraj says if there was a poll
again actually there will be even
stronger representation to get Britain
out because a lot of people now feel
whatever happened three years ago just
get it done now I could bore everyone to
death with arguments that I've been with
before that I believe the European Union
is collapsing I was a I was a leaver but
a reluctantly but no he's all
guys have heard that before so I just
parked that there if you're right then
it sounded how come the brexit part is
so successful well let's look at what
the breakfast party actually did in the
European elections 54 percent of voters
voted for parties who explicitly Apple
watch page 4.5 in the European elections
yeah vote for parties whose manifestos
explicitly oppose No Deal
yes no you're not saying bricks a party
won the elections they had been they
were the largest party but that's what I
call a way that's because there were
several parties for a remain there were
several parties for stuff we're not
having a deal brexit if you're the only
party offering a No Deal brexit and
there are several parties saying we
should have a second referendum just
because that their votes are split
doesn't mean that more people want the
thing that got fewer votes can I just
interrupt for one second did the brexit
parties only I know that only policy it
had was brexit but was it specifically a
No Deal breaks it Michelle you consider
running for them I mean would you have
campaigned for a No Deal brexit as
opposed to just brexit well what I think
when you say you talk about undemocratic
well I think and to be fair to you I do
actually respect I've seen a lot of what
your previous work and I respect what
you're doing because it's a cause you're
passionate about and you're endeavouring
to educate people about it but I
completely disagree with you and what I
think is undemocratic is the mess that
we're in now we should never be three
years on from this situation and have a
had our very ignored and rejected and
push back and push back and it's
something I feel very strongly about so
when we're now talking about an ER deal
scenario
it's for two parties to come together to
create a deal and it has to be a deal
that works for both people but whilst
you're negotiating something it is
absolutely backward and then some to
have removed no deal from the table and
to continue talking about removing no
deal from the table that for me makes me
so frustrated so if you're going to ask
me the question would I have campaign
for a No Deal
I think that actually no deal is better
than a bad deal I do I believe that
mantra can I can I come in on that I
think you should remind everybody you
also campaigned in that election but
they're more people sitting around this
table and vote before you will do carry
on 46,000 people can be wrong
I think that I mean I'm absolutely with
Femi on this I think that's for if the
governing Tory party that was
responsible or governing during the
miners strike during poll tax riots
during austerity during the financial
crash then impose no deal on this
country this party will never recover no
deal as every single sensible person in
the country has pointed out will cause a
crash where does it put my brother I
think I mean can we just you know what
we are seeing is two candidates duking
it out in a while' waving contest to try
and attract the votes of 160,000 Tory
membership members who for whom no deal
has become a virility symbol for the
breath for the brexit yeah let's see I
was gonna bout to say that she isn't a
Brahmin let's hear from my brother see
what yes yeah
don't forget that there will of course
logically be available to the government
if we are first returned to can I turn
it in this will be the decision of our
European friends and partners by the way
let's be absolutely clear it will be
they who've decided not to give us the
standstill that is so office it will be
their decision not to go there will be a
39 billion pound difficult that we will
be able to spend on mitigating anything
so he thinks it's the e useful if we go
for no deal but here's what his main
rival has to say no deal will be very
scary to a lot of people it's actually
pretty similar we're both saying that we
don't want it but if it's the only way
to deliver brexit we'd do it as Prime
Minister I will always be straight with
people and no deal will be disruptive to
businesses up and down the country
disruptive to the farming industry to
the fishing community and I am someone
who comes from a business background and
I know what it's like when a business is
under pressure because of a sudden
change in the market that you can't
control so I think we can all agree on
one thing and that is that actually when
people voted for brexit which they did
and my side lost your side lost to your
side lost but you kind of were a
reluctant leaver I think so your side
reluctantly Wiseman and Michelle won
right so I think one thing we can all
agree on is that nobody at when they
votes for brexit intentionally wanted a
No Deal scenario because none of the
leaders of the brexit campaign what
campaigning on that platform
exactly outright so I think we would
behoove us to acknowledge that so then
we can recognize that actually this
isn't a desired outcome and we should
try and do everything possible to avoid
it lot of what what I would also just
finding on it I say is actually what is
it probably helping us up until this and
now and I'm going to be sensible what
probably isn't helping us up until this
stage is the language and the discourse
being used see what brexit are saying
it's undemocratic that the referendum
hasn't been delivered when actually they
tried to deliver it you know people
didn't like suiza may steal I didn't
like to his base deal and we got you
know our side also I don't think we
should call it undemocratic what's
happening now because actually they're
calling us under Democratic as well and
it's whether you know they're racists or
we're traitors and we end up in that
kind of you know in the gutter and I
don't think it helps us get out of the
problem where the reason we're in this
problem is because nobody wants to
compromise nobody wants to budge from
their positions and the language we use
actually entrenches as fun Democratic if
let's say the next Tory leader suspends
incorporates Parliament in order to
force through something that nobody
voted for where there's no popular I you
know clever cetera Haarlem entry
mandates
I mean I'd argue that the Prime Minister
winnings selected is undemocratic but
actually that's that's the precise thing
bricks it was completely undefined in
2016 because it could have resulted in
all the different types of deals who
could end up having but the fact is in
2017 the majority 54 percent voted for
parties whose manifestos explicitly
ruled out no deal that makes no deal
against that's a good question which our
new Michelle Rasmussen do you want that
I'm saying that given that we were
promised a deal out most pretzels were
promised a deal it was only logical to
give we now negotiated that deal so
people don't have any time for any other
reason why he knows yes because the
reason the moment you put no dill in the
bowel paper the leave side will say
don't worry No Deal is only temporary
which means they'll be arguing for a
deal for the majority of their No Deal
campaign you want a vote with romaine
and romaine lights it's not remain like
it's the deal I'll be out of the EU for
leave with a deal we are the EU for
leave with the deal well first and
foremost it depends on what that deal is
if you're in a situation whereby you
cannot even strike your own trade deal
we out of my question this is a matter
of law when we triggered article 50 it
meant that after two years or upon the
passing of the withdrawal again which is
what it says in article 50 in those
treaties the treaties no longer applied
to us which means we're out of the EU as
a matter of law the deal we've just
negotiated fulfills the referendum
mandate so that if you don't like that
then clearly the referendum in 2016
what's gonna happen in three weeks after
Parliament comes back from conferences
and we have three weeks with whoever the
next PM is likely to be Boris what can
we possibly achieve when those three
weeks we are this I feel so frustrated I
like I said I respect your position but
it frustrates me because at the end of
the day the situation is we did fur and
you will be bored of hearing people
repeat this I didn't vote for no we
voted to leave the European Union now
what is no deal no deal if you won't say
that it's a formal set of arrangements
now if people had have taken that
seriously and businesses understood what
these arrangements look like because
when you say No Deal it's making out
like there's nothing that there are
formal arrangements and if it was
communicated and documented properly
businesses could prepare for that and
it's this chewing and throwing and
blocking of this and it really we are
sorry